you only get one chance to make a first
impression and that's true if you're a
robot as well as if you're a person and
the first time that I met one of these
robots was at a place called Willow
Garage in 2008 and when I went to visit
there my host walked me into the
building and we met this little guy he
was rolling into the hallway came up to
me sat there stared blankly past me did
nothing for a while rapidly spun his
head around 180 degrees and then ran
away and that was not a great first
impression the thing that I learned
about robots that day is that you know
they they kind of do their own thing and
they're not totally aware of us and I
think as we're experimenting with these
possible robot futures we actually end
up learning a lot more about ourselves
as opposed to just these machines and
what I learned that day was that I had
pretty high expectations for this little
dude right he was not only supposed to
be able to navigate the physical world
but also be able to navigate my social
world he's in my space it's a personal
robot why didn't understand me and my
host explained to me that well the
robots trying to get from point A to
point B and you were an obstacle in his
way so he had to replan his path figure
out where to go and then get there some
other way which was actually not a very
efficient thing to do if that robot had
figured out that I was a person not a
chair and that I was willing to get out
of its way if it was trying to get
somewhere then it actually it would have
been more efficient at getting its job
done if it had bothered to notice that I
was a human and that I have different
affordances than things like chairs and
walls do you know we tend to think of
these robots as being from outer space
and from the future and from
science-fiction and while that could be
true I'd actually like to argue that
robots are here today and they live and
work amongst us right now these are two
robots that live in my home they vacuum
the floors and they cut the grass every
single day which is more than I would do
if I actually had time to do these tests
and they'd probably do it better than I
would too this one actually takes care
of my kitty every single time he uses
the box it cleans it which is not
something I'm willing to do and it
actually makes his life better as well
as mine and while we call these robot
products right that's a robot vacuum
cleaner it's a
lawnmower it's a robot litter box I
think there's actually a bunch of other
robots hiding in plain sight that it
just becomes so darn useful and so darn
mundane that we call them things like
dishwasher right they get new names they
don't get called robot anymore because
they actually serve a purpose in our
lives
similarly a thermostat right I know my
robotics friends out there probably
cringing at me calling this a robot but
it has a goal its goal is to make my
house 66 degrees Fahrenheit and it
senses the world it knows it's a little
bit cold it makes a plan and then it
acts on the physical world
it's robotics even if it might not look
like Rosie the robot it's doing
something that's that's really useful in
my life so I don't have to take care of
turning the temperature up and down
myself and I think you know these
systems live and work amongst us now and
not only are these systems living
amongst us but you are probably are
about operator too when you drive your
car it feels like you're operating
machinery you're also going from point A
to point B but your car probably has
power steering it probably has automatic
braking systems it might have an
automatic transmission and maybe even
adaptive cruise control and while it
might not be a fully autonomous car it
has bits of autonomy and they're so
useful and they make us drive safer that
and we just sort of feel like they're
invisible in use right so when you're
driving your car you should just feel
like you're going from one place to
another it doesn't feel like it's this
big thing that you have to deal with and
operate and use these controls because
we spend so long learning how to drive
that they've become sort of extensions
of ourselves when you park that car in
that tight little garage space you know
where your corners are and when you
drive a rental car that maybe you
haven't driven before you take some time
to get used to your new robot body and
this is also true for people who operate
other types of robots so I'd like to
share with you a few stories about that
dealing with the problem of remote
collaboration so at Willow Garage I had
a co-worker named Dallas and Dallas look
like this he worked from his home in
Indiana in our company in California and
so he was a voice in a box on the table
and most of our meetings which is kind
of ok except
you know if we had a really heated
debate and we didn't really like what he
was saying we might just hang up on him
ah and then we might have a meeting
after that meeting and you know actually
make the decisions in the hallway after
whereas when he wasn't there anymore and
that so wasn't so great for him and as a
robotics company at Willow Wright we had
some mixture of robot body parts laying
around so Dallas and his buddy Kurt put
together this thing which looks kind of
like Skype on a stick on wheels which
seems like a techy silly toy but really
it's probably one of the most powerful
tools that I've seen ever made for
remote collaboration so now if I didn't
answer Dallas's email question right he
could literally roll into my office
block my doorway and ask me the question
again until I answered it and I'm not
gonna turn him off right that's kind of
rude not only was it good for these
one-on-one communications but also for
just showing up at the company All Hands
meeting right getting your butt in that
chair and showing people that you're
present and committed to your project is
a big deal and can help remote
collaboration a ton and it we saw this
over the period of months and in years
not only in our company but at others
too
the best thing that can happen with
these systems is that it starts to feel
like you're just there right it's just
you it's just your body and so people
actually start to give these things
personal space so when you're having a
stand-up meeting people will sort of
stand around the space just as they
would if you were there in person and
that's great until there's breakdowns
and it's not and so people you know when
they first see these robots are like wow
where's the components oh there must be
a camera over then they start poking
your face you're talking too softly I'm
gonna turn up your volume which is kind
of like having a co-worker walk up to
you and saying you're speaking too
softly I'm gonna turn up your face right
that's awkward and not okay and so we
end up having to build these new social
norms around using these systems
similarly you know as you start feeling
like it's your body you start noticing
things like oh my robots kind of short
and so Dallas would say things to me he
was six foot tall and we would take him
via robot - you know cocktail parties
and things like that as you do and the
robot was about five foot tall which is
close to my height and he would tell me
you know people are not really looking
at me I feel like I'm just looking at
the sea of shoulders
and it just thought we need a taller
robot and I told him no you get to walk
in my shoes for today you get to see
what it's like to be on the shorter end
of the spectrum and he actually ended up
building a lot of empathy for that
experience which was kind of great so
when he'd come in as an in person he no
longer stood over me as he was talking
to me he would sit down and talk to me I
to I which is kind of a beautiful thing
and so we actually decided to look at
this in the laboratory and see if what
other kinds of differences things like
robot height would make and so half of
the people in our study use a shorter
robot half of the people in our study
used a taller robot and we actually
found that the exact same person who has
the exact same body and says the exact
same things to someone is more
persuasive and perceived as being more
credible if they're in a taller robot
form makes no rational sense but that's
why we study psychology and really you
know the way that cliff Nass would put
this is that we're having to deal with
these new technologies despite the fact
that we have very old brains right human
psychology is not changing at the same
speed the tech is and so we're always
playing catch-up and trying to make
sense of this world where these
autonomous things are running around and
usually things that talk are people not
machines right and so we breathe a lot
of meaning into things like just height
of a machine not a person and attribute
that to the person using the system you
know this I think is really important
when you're thinking about robotics it's
not so much about reinventing humans
it's more about figuring out how we
extend ourselves right and we end up
using these things in ways that are sort
of surprising so these guys are you know
they can't play pool because the robots
don't have arms but they can't heckle
the guys who are playing pool and and
that can be an important thing for team
bonding which is kind of neat people who
get really good at operating these
systems will even do things like make up
new games like robot soccer in the
middle of the night I'm pushing the
trash cans around but not everyone's
good a lot of people have trouble
operating these systems this is actually
a guy who logged into the robot and his
eyeball was turned 90 degrees to the
left he didn't know that and so he ended
up just bashing around the office
running into people's desk getting super
embarrassed laughing about it his volume
is way too high and this guy here in the
the image is telling me like we need
robot mute button and by that what he
really meant was we don't want it to be
so disruptive so as a robotics company
we added some obstacle avoidance to the
system it got a little laser rangefinder
that could see the obstacles and if eyes
are about operator try to say run into a
chair it wouldn't let me it would just
plan a path around which seems like a
good idea people did hit fewer obstacles
using that system obviously but actually
for some of the people it took them a
lot longer to get through our obstacle
course and we wanted to know why it
turns out that there's this important
human dimension a personality invention
called locus of control and people who
have a strong internal locus of control
they need to be the masters of their own
destiny really don't like giving up
control to an autonomous system so much
so that they will fight the autonomy if
I want to hit that chair I'm gonna hit
that chair and so they would actually
suffer from having that autonomous
assistance which is an important thing
for us to know as we're building
increasingly autonomous safe cars right
how are different people going to
grapple with that loss of control it's
going to be different depending on human
dimensions we we can't treat humans as
if we're just one monolithic thing we
vary by personality by culture we even
vary by emotional state moment to moment
and being able to design these systems
that's human robot interaction systems
and we need to take into account the
human dimensions not just the
technological ones along with a sense of
control also comes a sense of
responsibility and if you were in robot
operator using one of these systems this
is what the interface would look like it
looks a little bit like a video game
which can be good because that's very
familiar to people but it can also be
bad because it makes people feel like
it's a video game we had a bunch of kids
over at Stanford play with the system
and drive the robot around our office in
Menlo Park and the kids started saying
things like ten points have you hit that
guy over there 20 points for that one
and they would chase him down the
hallway right I told them those are real
people they're actually gonna bleed and
feel pain if you hit them and they'd be
there okay got it but it's five minutes
later they'd be like oh and 20 points
with that guy over there he just looks
like he needs to get hit and so it's a
little bit like Ender's Game
like there is a real world on that other
side and I think it's our responsibility
as people designing these interfaces to
help people remember that there's real
consequences to their actions and to
feel a sense of responsibility when
they're operating these increasingly
autonomous things these are kind of a
great example of you know experimenting
with one possible robotic future and I
think it's pretty cool that we can
extend ourselves and learn about the
ways that we extend ourselves into these
machines while at the same time being
able to express our humanity and our
personality we also build empathy for
others in terms of being a shorter
taller faster slower and maybe even
armless which is kind of neat we also
build empathy for the robots themselves
so this is one of my favorite robots is
called the tween but and this guy has a
little flag that says I'm trying to get
to this intersection in Manhattan and
it's cute and rolls forward that's it it
doesn't know how to build a map it
doesn't know how to see the world it
just asks for help and the nice thing
about people is that it you know it can
actually depend upon the kindness of
strangers it did make it across the park
to the other side of Manhattan which is
pretty great just because people would
pick it up and point in the right
direction
and that's great right I think you know
we're trying to build this human robot
world in which we can co-exist and
collaborate with one another and we
don't need to be fully autonomous and
just do things on our own we actually do
things together and to make that happen
we actually need help from people like
the artists and the designers the
policymakers the legal scholars
psychologists sociologists
anthropologists we need more
perspectives in the room if we're going
to do the thing that's to card says we
should do which is you know invent the
future that we actually want to live in
and I think you know we can continue to
experiment with these different robotic
futures together and in doing so we end
up we will end up learning a lot more
about ourselves thank you
[Applause]
[Music]